Al Gore bring this up Jordan Al Gore is
going to create an inconvenient truth
sequel so he's pretty happy about that
he's going to be creating the
inconvenient truth sequel and a British
High Court ruled this isn't this is not
a conspirator I twinkle Spira see
anti-science conspiracy a British High
Court ruled that there were nine
significant factual errors in an
inconvenient truth but they still
allowed it in schools certainly there's
nine significant errors but we're still
going to allow this to be shown in
schools with Al Gore I'm sure you just
must have jumped out of your seat when
you heard that he was doing an
inconvenient truth - did you not did you
not know about this well you know what
you know what's extraordinary steven is
I'm just amazed he's alive
by the way he said he said that we would
be all dead by now so I just think we
should take a moment and celebrate the
fact that we're even here Steven because
you know a lot of people said we'd be
dead now obviously they've been saying
we've gone for a really long time but Al
Gore said of them you know you know you
just like Al Gore he was on a cherry
picker he was telling us stuff and
anyway we're here Steven so a lot to
celebrate I'm not sure what his films
gonna be about of everything he said was
basically wrong so it's the story with
the polar bear yeah there's the story
and they're really fast and they're
hanging out in huge numbers in
record-breaking numbers like a 40-year
high in the population of polar bears
it's a really good time for polar bears
yeah if anything they're just getting a
lot a very very fat because life is good
life is lovely for the for the polar
bears you know I I'm really curious to
see this new movie of Al Gore's because
I'm one really easy
is he gonna just drop his polar bears
because obviously the two polar bears
have let Al Gore down and we're all
disappointed by that but they abhor
bears have not had not I which is sad
for them cuz they took him in as one of
their own Healey Booker's have not heard
the news about their own extinction John
Holdren said that by 2020 a billion
people would be dead because basically
of our use of fossil fuels yeah you know
when when do they you know that thing
and love is never having to say you're
sorry right when do they say they're
sorry like when did they say they sorry
yeah an Al Gore said ten years ago if we
didn't take drastic drastic steps to
change our behavior we would reach that
and I wish we had music for this Steven
we have already returned so we should
just you know burn all the fossil fuels
we like Gordon Brown who was the prime
minister not an idiot a priming that
well let's maybe debate it's up for the
Gordon Brown who was the Prime Minister
of the United of the United Kingdom in
2009 said we had 50 days 50 days left 50
days left to save the planet
Prince Charles Oh bless his heart Prince
Charles who you know we have the very
funny video about him Prince Charles
hypocrisy said in 2009 we had 96 months
left to save the planet
he will Rajendra Pachauri country whose
name I'm sure I'm butchering right ahead
of the IPCC said in 2007 we had four
years to save the planet I don't know
maybe these guys should get together and
come up with some kind of consensus on
when it isn't all about today George
Monbiot who we really do love from the
Guardian said in 2002 that in 10 years
the world would have to choose between
feeding the animals on the planet mhm or
feeding the people but we couldn't have
both well let's just feed the people
with the animals that doesn't even seem
like that I think it's extraordinary you
know how easy it is for elites who have
a de life that Al Gore has the beautiful
life that he has flying around in planes
and having lovely dinners and being warm
and his lovely house and in other houses
and you know just using loads and loads
of fossil fuels and being really wealthy
and that he would impose on the poor of
the world an alternative to fossil fuels
when fossil fuels have worked out so
well for all of us and we're living
these very safe lives by the way we have
our children if they get sick going to
hospitals where we're not relying on the
wind blowing or the sun shining the
electricity to be to be on but he's
imposing that kind of those kind of or
that awful
unreliable energy on the developing
world and I just think it's as you said
there's a really tragic sight it isn't
funny at all we have a preview now for
ten years later an inconvenient truth to
Al Gore seems excited about it a decade
ago I released my Academy award-winning
documentary An Inconvenient Truth it was
met with great applause fanfare and cold
hard cash but to my dismay an
everlasting shame a British High Court
ruled that many of my facts were
unfounded and outright misleading
legally obligated me to produce this
sequel I found out that the ice caps
were not melting but in many parts of
the world gaining more ice and they were
losing and that polar bears are in fact
not endangered but alive and well also
they're kind of ass I was extremely
surprised to find out that sea levels
were not actually rising so fast as to
threaten all the coastal cities I'd
warned about allowing me to stay in my
beachfront mansion although I still sit
on the board of Apple and finally I
learned that carbon dioxide is
necessarily not in fact a pollutant but
a byproduct of the planet's natural
cycle necessary for all living beings
fan hold up I'm just finishing my movie
trailer narration and Inconvenient Truth
- in theaters 2017 okay if you like this
video subscribe by clicking the button
that says subscribe if you're not aware
of it now there's no way you're learning
the Internet at this point I'm not going
to help you but this was clipped from my
daily show available exclusively to
lotto with credit com / mug club members
of your student military or veteran
internet promo code it's less than six
dollars a month and you get daily
content no more clips Plus this hand
etched mug
oh I just when I feel it I got a chill
like on the inside